à première vue on croirait une ligne
désaffectée pourtant chaque jour 14
trains y circulent transportant en
moyenne 700 voyageurs 56 km entre
Valençay et Salbris chaotique car en
grande partie abîmée par le temps ça
pouvait occasionner des nuisances sur la
circulation des trains et donc là
maintenant on va retrouver un confort
voilà au niveau circulation éviter
d'être baloté sur la voile sera beaucoup
plus stable aucun train ne circule cet
été c'est la période idéale pour
réaliser ce chantier puisque 85% des
voyageurs qui l'empruntent sont des
scolaires la Région finance les 9
millions d'euros de travaux pour
développer la fréquentation et maintenir
ouverte tous les guichets comme ici à
Valençay on voit qu'il y a une montée en
puissance mais il faut plus de plus
d'activités des activités touristiques
des activités intermodales autour du
vélo je crois qu'il y a plein de choses
à mettre en oeuvre pour relancer la
dynamique et on a sauvé l'infrastructure
maintenant il faut augmenter l'offre
augmenter les services rendus à la
population et au territoire l'autre
enjeu est d'améliorer le maillage
ferroviaire du territoire à Salbris les
usagers peuvent déjà correspondre avec
les Intercités de la ligne Paris
Toulouse depuis l'année dernière et
jusqu'à au milieu de 2024 l'ensemble des
lignes de dessertes fines du territoire
vont être pérennisées tout l'orge tour
Chinon donc celle que nous on appelle
Dourdan la Membrolle les Chartres courte
Alain cette ligne et donc bourge
Montluçon qui en plus dès l'année
prochaine revient dans le réseau
structurant la circulation reprendra fin
août l'été prochain les travaux
concerneront le tronçon entre Salbris et
Romorantin